I was there thought all day
sitting a shot block is up the street a
cop guy shot about midnight the crowd
head began to dwindle till about 40 or
so protesters we heard three to four
gunshots we all turned in the direction
of the gun shots behind us are many
folks took cover others ran and chaos
ensues and we pray that non-violence
will become the mainstay of both the
police piece as well as our community we
have been clear that we deplore all
forms of violence and so it actually is
upon us now have to be more vigilant and
more articulate in our critique of the
forms of policing and violence of our
communities have been subject subjugated
to not only in Ferguson but throughout
the country
you